[MUSIC PLAYING]
WAYNE SUTTON: Hi,
I'm Wayne Sutton.
MELINDA EPLER:
I'm Melinda Epler.
We're the founders
of Change Catalyst.
We empower inclusive and
sustainable innovation
globally through startup
ecosystem and tech inclusion
programs
WAYNE SUTTON: Welcome
to this series sponsored
by Women Techmakers,
Google's initiative that
provides visibility,
community, and resources
for women in technology.
MELINDA EPLER: Together we're
helping tech hub leaders
to develop more inclusive tech
cultures, programs, and spaces.
In an ever expanding
tech economy,
tech hubs are the centers
of innovation for cities
and regions around the world.
WAYNE SUTTON: A
tech hub is usually
a physical space
or community that
provides educational
opportunities, meet ups,
events, and co-working spaces.
It may also house an
incubator or accelerator.
MELINDA EPLER: Inside
a tech hub you'll
find a community of
entrepreneurs, engineers,
investors, and community
leaders building innovative tech
products and services.
WAYNE SUTTON: Tech hubs
provide support to early stage
startups, access to mentorship,
and new team members' skills
building and career development,
shared spaces, and learning.
As well as formal and
informal opportunities
for collaboration.
MELINDA EPLER:
We're going to talk
about diversity and inclusion
a lot in this series.
Here's how we define it--
diversity is bringing people to
the table from a wide variety
of backgrounds.
But it's not enough just
to sit at the table,
inclusion invites them to speak
and encourages them to lead.
You need both together
for your team to thrive.
WAYNE SUTTON: A fully
inclusive culture
is one where
everyone is welcome,
accepted, respected,
supported, and able to thrive
across all genders, races,
ethnicities, abilities,
religious beliefs, veteran
status, geographic origins,
sexual orientations, ages,
social economic backgrounds.
MELINDA EPLER: When
we're all included,
we all feel happier and produce
better business results.
We love coming to work,
we have more confidence,
we're more productive, and we
can show up as our full selves.
Our staff satisfaction
increases, turnover decreases,
and we all invest
in our workplace.
Tech hubs are the center
of innovation for cities,
and collaboration
between diverse peoples
creates the best solutions.
Inclusive teams solve
problems for everyone.
Innovation must come from
all of us, for all of us.
WAYNE SUTTON: Tech is the
most rapidly growing sector
with some of the
highest paying jobs.
Yet, right now, it's
leaving people out.
This is what we call the
wealth and opportunity gap.
At the same time, there are many
unfulfilled tech jobs, which
is continuing to increase.
MELINDA EPLER: Yeah, tech is
one of the few industries where
you can enter the workplace
with the right skills
in under a year.
WAYNE SUTTON: Right
now, tech is losing
out on this great opportunity
by not including more people.
MELINDA EPLER: Increasing
diversity and inclusion
can dramatically affect
the products you make
and the bottom line
for your company.
Here's the data-- diverse
and inclusive teams show 22%
greater productivity, 39%
higher customer satisfaction.
Gender diverse leadership
teams have 15% higher
financial returns, and
ethnically diverse leadership
teams have 35% higher
financial returns.
WAYNE SUTTON: We all
have a role to play
in solving diversity
and inclusion in tech,
because we all had a role in
creating the imbalances that
currently keep under-represented
people out of tech.
MELINDA EPLER: There
is a network effect.
WAYNE SUTTON: Access to
capital and jobs in tech
both rely on networks that some
people don't have access to.
Even understanding
the tech culture
and how the tech
industry operates
can be tough for people
who aren't currently
inside the tech industry.
MELINDA EPLER: There's
a tech education
gap that starts in early
childhood education
and grows larger from there.
Without early digital
access and role models,
kids are less likely to
be interested in tech
in the first place.
And even if they
become interested,
unless they attend
an elite school,
they're less likely to
be hired for a tech role.
WAYNE SUTTON: There's
a false meritocracy
in the tech industry.
There is a belief
that everyone gets
to the top due to
their own merit,
and that others who
aren't at the top
just didn't have the
skills to get there.
But our systems are
created for, and by,
a homogeneous culture that
actively, and passively, leaves
out the majority of
the world's population.
MELINDA EPLER: Where skills
and the ability to learn
are universal,
opportunity is not.
WAYNE SUTTON: There's also
a lack of representation
in media, in textbooks,
in toys, and in films.
If you can see
it, you can be it.
But if you don't see
it, you might not
think tech is a
real path for you.
MELINDA EPLER: Changing
behavior is hard, too,
and full of economic
and emotional barriers.
We're humans with
biases that affect
our judgments about people.
WAYNE SUTTON: To
be more inclusive,
we must work on our
own empathy for others
and acknowledge and
filter our own biases.
MELINDA EPLER: And to have
more inclusive tech companies
and tech hubs, we have to change
a lot of individual behaviors.
This is not an easy task and
takes both time and resources.
WAYNE SUTTON: But
it is worth it.
When you develop an inclusive
culture at your tech hub,
you will be rewarded
with an innovation
ecosystem that truly thrives.
It's good for business, it's
good for the local economy,
it's good for the world.
Watch the series of videos to
learn how you and your team
can address these issues and
become a more inclusive tech
hub.
MELINDA EPLER: It starts with
measurement and accountability,
the role of leadership in
diversity and inclusion,
creating an inclusive culture.
WAYNE SUTTON: Expanding
your diversity goals
through external
programs, and create
inclusive physical
spaces in your hub.
For more information
about Women Techmakers,
Change Catalyst, and additional
resources, see the links below.
MELINDA EPLER: Share this
series with your community,
and let's work together
to create inclusive tech
hubs around the world.
[MUSIC PLAYING]